so I wanted to show you this amazing
music video that these two crazy guys
made for me let me know what you think
of it
one day you'll be my just thing comes up
my talent you say hardest thing guys and
I just think if I just need I have a
crush on you just
what am I to do just ease when I can't
get over you just me I can't lie
Hajus
i many jobs but none like Steve Jobs if
I was an apple girl you would be my
heart and you will be my hard drive
through your motherboard baby girl I'm
loving your style can I discover more up
your laptop but you know your brush your
honor they making the body let go wrong
on you a honey travel to the enter the
net for this girl maybe one day I will
be in this
what am I to do when I can't get over
you just
it is but I'm the Mac Pro give me a
chance to make your final cut studio
grab my time capsule to travel back to 6
at the Genius Bar jumping all your twit
pics with the club through the VMAs go
to another place so bad before you ever
thrown a now scott james before for 3g
an Apple TV yourself - because
they you'll be my just
you say you just speak
when I can't get over you just
if you like the song you can download it
there's a link in the description over
there and don't forget to subscribe to
their channels